[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
BRENDAN COLLINS: Hi everyone.
Welcome.
I'm Brendan Collins.
This is special Talks At event
that we have for you today.
Pleased to be welcoming
some folks from the show
"Natasha, Pierre, and
the Great Comet of 1812."
It's a fantastic, incredible
musical unlike anything
you've ever seen.
So just to quickly
intro the four guests--
Dave Malloy.
He's the writer and
composer of the show.
Rachel Chavkin is the director.
Brittain Ashford plays Sonya.
And Josh Groban plays the
title character of Pierre.
So please join me in
welcoming Dave, Rachel,
Brittain, and Josh.
[APPLAUSE]
Welcome.
JOSH GROBAN: Oh no.
I'm going to blend
into the curtain.
BRENDAN COLLINS:
Google camouflage.
We're working on it.
So welcome.
Thanks for coming.
So just to quickly--
I know a bunch of people
have seen the show.
But for those of you
who haven't, the show
is an adaptation of a small
chunk of "War and Peace," which
might not strike you as Broadway
material right off the bat.
But it basically
tells the story--
it's a complicated
Robert Altman-esque
weaving of a lot of story
lines and characters.
But it basically tracks Natasha
and Pierre and their two lives
as they intersect in 19th
century aristocrat Russia.
But as you saw in the clip, it's
a pretty incredible experience.
It's a genre-bending
kind of whirlwind
that never comes up for air.
And it's an incredible thing.
And one of the best
descriptions of it
comes from Anthony Tommasini
from the "New York Times."
And forgive me when I
flatter you to your faces,
but Mr. Malloy especially.
The show lifts styles
with such abandon,
making willful shifts
from punk rifts
to agitated Broadway
ballads, mock pompous
recitative to gritty
Russian folk songs,
or drinking Corson's
with klezmer clarinets.
You eventually lose track of
what is being appropriated
and you stop caring.
So the result is almost like--
you know, it's a pastiche,
like a Tarantino, almost,
experience.
So the first
question is for Dave.
So you're the
creator of the show.
DAVE MALLOY: Sure.
BRENDAN COLLINS:
Thank you I know
you've told the story before.
But how did you come up with
the idea for a musical based
on "War and Peace."
DAVE MALLOY: I mean,
it was really just
upon reading the novel
for the first time.
For whatever reason
this particular section
immediately sang out to me.
Yeah.
I famously was working on
a cruise ship at the time.
So I was in a very
particular mental space.
And I was actually feeling
very, very much a social misfit
aboard the ship.
I was working on the ship.
And it just wasn't
really my social scene.
So I really related
to Pierre, who
is this character who was just
a profoundly awkward person.
[LAUGHTER]
And yeah.
I just really related
to his sense of kind
of being kind of
lost in this society
and not quite knowing how
to act, and really also just
super searching, and having--
Pierre is this deeply
philosophical, spiritually
lost character.
And throughout the entire
novel he's just searching.
So when I read this particular--
when I was reading the novel
I was so relating to Pierre.
And then I got to this
particular 70-page section.
And there was
something about the way
that Tolstoy wove
the two stories
of Pierre's existential
crisis, and then Natasha
having this first romantic
disaster of her young life,
and the way that these
two stories kind of ran
in parallel for a while,
and then intersected just
at the very end.
And it really just reminded
me of the structure
of a classic musical--
the kind of two couple
structure of two stories
kind of running in parallel
that intersect at one point.
And I loved how it
kind of subverted
that, in that it wasn't
too romantic couples.
It was one romantic couple
and one spiritual couple.
You know, Pierre and God, or
Pierre and existence, or Pierre
and the rest of the world.
BRENDAN COLLINS: Right.
So you take that seed from the--
whatever cruise ship you're on.
How do you get it to the first
staging, which was at Ars Nova?
Any Ars Nova fans in the house?
Whoo!
Cool.
Anyways, how do you take that
idea and bring it on stage?
DAVE MALLOY: I mean, yeah.
The terrifying thing-- the
thing about the Ars Nova is they
had seen another show
of mine, "Beowulf,
A Thousand Years of
Baggage," which was
a rock opera based on Beowulf.
And based on the
strength of that,
they invited me to be their
composer in residence one year.
And so being a
composer in residence,
you get a commission from them.
So they're like, you know,
what do you want to do?
What's your dream project to do?
And so I had had this "War and
Peace" idea kind of tucked away
in the back of my head.
And I very sheepishly-- like
thoroughly expecting to be shot
down--
offered this idea.
Like, well, what
if we did a musical
based on a little bit
of "War and Peace"?
And this is like a 90-seat
theater, a very, very small
theater.
So I thought they'd be like,
why don't we try something that
maybe just has two characters?
You know, something very small.
But much to my-- yeah.
Much to my surprise and horror,
they enthusiastically said yes.
And then I was like, oh, god.
So now I have to write it?
BRENDAN COLLINS:
Well, you know, it's
just amazing how it's
evolved over the years.
Because when-- it premiered at
Ars Nova in 2012, I believe.
So Rachel, actually,
you've also been
involved with the show since
its inception at Ars Nova.
And you've been right
there alongside Dave
as you've sort of helped it
evolve into the amazing thing
that it's become.
So over the years--
and the set itself.
You caught a glimpse
of it in the clip.
But it looks like if Tolstoy
had a mansion in Palm Springs,
basically.
It's this amazing throwback.
But it's also a little run down.
And it's just-- it's
such a visceral thing.
JOSH GROBAN: It is now.
RACHEL CHAVKIN: We're
trying to maintain it.
BRENDAN COLLINS: Yeah.
A lot of wear and tear.
But there's some
amazing statistics
about the actual set.
So there's 262
individual light bulbs
in 31 chandeliers on the set.
And there's 126,000 Swarovski
crystals in the costumes.
RACHEL CHAVKIN: Yeah.
BRENDAN COLLINS: How
do you maintain--
but from starting in
a 90-person theater,
how do you maintain
that intimacy
as you go to 1,400 seats?
RACHEL CHAVKIN: Yeah.
I mean, I think the really
wonderful thing about how
the show developed and
moved to Broadway--
because all four of us made our
Broadway debuts with this show,
as did almost the entirety
of our creative team
and almost the
entirety of our cast.
So this is really a show that
has come from the pavement
to Broadway.
And what's been wonderful
about that journey
is that it grew slowly.
So starting with
87 seats, we really
figured out, in the poorest
theater sense of the word,
what was essential and what
was the DNA of the show.
Which very much-- there
is a huge amount of--
there is no fourth wall.
And there literally can't be,
because the set is everywhere.
The actors are constantly
swirling around the audience
and behind the audience.
And that was the case
even at Ars Nova.
And one of the big reasons for
that was because, you know,
when you're reading a novel, you
have this incredibly intimate
experience.
It's a one-on-one experience.
And either the character
is talking directly
to you, or in the
case of Tolstoy,
that narration is
directly to you.
So getting that DNA
in place at Ars Nova,
which forced such intimacy--
I mean, we were exploding
out that theater space--
meant that when the
time came to get bigger,
it was never a question
of what the DNA was.
It was never a
question as to what
we would be enlarging, just
how we were going to do it.
And so along the
way, that's been--
we went from 10 performers--
10 actors, I should
say-- and a band of six
at Ars Nova, just
the 10 principals,
to adding an ensemble of six.
And then when we transferred
to ART, which was slightly
over 500 seats, that grew to an
ensemble, full, onstage, of 24.
And then now on Broadway
it's 30 people on stage.
And one of the
reasons for that is
to make sure that we
have enough actors
to take care of as many
audience sections as we have.
But the look of
the show has been
the same since the beginning.
It's red velvet curtains.
And Mimi calls it being
inside a Faberge egg,
or like a dream of Russia--
Mimi Lien who is our scenic
designer, has been obviously
a huge partner in this.
BRENDAN COLLINS: And
it's really amazing.
You kind of just
hit it on the head.
I was trying to figure
out how you translate it
as it gets bigger and bigger.
And as you have, you
mentioned, the DNA
of the show, that can
scale sort of endlessly.
RACHEL CHAVKIN: Yes.
Exactly.
BRENDAN COLLINS: But at the same
time as all of this stuff is
happening, you mentioned it's--
not chaotic.
But it's a swirl all the time.
But the story itself
is really grounded.
And it's a pretty universal
experience of, you know,
first crush, heartache,
loss, jealousy, power.
How do you keep the story as
the focus the whole time amidst
all this other stuff happening?
RACHEL CHAVKIN: Yeah.
I mean, I love-- that chaos
that you're talking about
is definitely my favorite
thing to see onstage.
And I can say confidently there
are moments in the production
now that I still
have never seen,
that are like tiny
moments where--
like at one time,
I was sitting--
and this was staged.
I mean, all of it's
staged in some way.
But during the duel
scene, which takes place
in a modern nightclub
setting within that space,
two people came over and
snorted lines off my table.
And you're like, oh, wow!
I saw that.
And the person right next
to me probably didn't.
But I think in terms of
the story being grounded,
it goes back to Dave's
initial question and response,
which is it's very pure
what the work is doing.
These two strands--
Natasha's rise and
downfall and Pierre's
spiritual resurrection.
And so when you have an
environment where everyone
knows what story
they're telling,
that actually allows for a huge
amount of individual freedom
within the larger structure.
And so I think
constantly as a cast,
we would just check in about
what the central story was
of a given scene, and how all
elements of the choreography--
which Sam Pinkelton has
been a huge partner in--
how all elements are
driving towards telling
the story of Pierre's
nightmare party, or almost
like Natasha's
bar mitzvah or bat
mitzvah during the
[INAUDIBLE] sequence.
So it's just staying grounded in
the really simple human action
that's at the center
of any moment.
BRENDAN COLLINS: So related
to watching the show grow
into what it's become,
Brittain, you've
also been involved with the
show since its early days.
So aside from the venue,
what's changed the most?
BRITTAIN ASHFORD: Oh.
I mean, it's crazy to me.
Because it's the venue
that has changed the most.
To me it's like the
story remains the same.
To me, the intimacy--
despite any reservations
I initially had--
ultimately is very
similar to me.
So it's kind of the size and
the scope of the audience
that we're able to reach.
Obviously our audience
itself is different.
You know, the type of people
who are willing to venture over
to 10th Avenue to Ars Nova
to an 88-seat cabaret theater
is different than
the average audience
goer who might be really
excited to come see Josh.
It's ultimately a
different audience.
I mean, there are folks
who come see the show who
know very little of Broadway,
but love Josh's work,
so they want to see it, or
know very little of Josh's work
and just know Broadway shows,
so they want to see it.
And then there's some people
who are just, like, I've
heard this is a great show.
So I want to see it.
It's a much wider net
than we ever had before,
which is very exciting.
But the thing that I'm
most proud about the show,
like from start to
where we are now,
is maintaining that intimacy.
In part because I
love the show so much.
And I never would have
thought, at the beginning--
you know, when Dave
approached me with this idea,
I thought, oh, well,
that sounds great.
I-- I don't know.
[LAUGHTER]
You know?
Like, oh, that
sounds really cool.
Really?
BRENDAN COLLINS: Yeah.
Did he call you from the cruise
ship to pitch you his idea?
BRITTAIN ASHFORD: No.
JOSH GROBAN: [INAUDIBLE] flare.
DAVE MALLOY: I had to
ply her with a beer
to convince her to do it.
BRITTAIN ASHFORD: This is true.
It was like, hey,
meet me at this bar.
I was like, cool.
Uh-- and he was like, OK,
I've got this great idea.
And I was like, oh.
Um, no, I don't think I'm
the person you want for that.
And he was like,
here's another beer.
And I was like, I'm pretty sure
I'm still not the person you
want for this.
And he was like, how
about one more beer.
RACHEL CHAVKIN: How
about a whiskey?
JOSH GROBAN: That's kind of
what I did to Dave to get
him to hire me, actually.
[LAUGHTER]
BRENDAN COLLINS:
I was actually--
because I've heard, Josh, in
other interviews you mentioned
that story of over
a drink or five,
you hashed out the
arrangement to join the show.
So, I mean, you're
obviously used
to performing consistently
and regularly.
But acting with other people
onstage was a new thing.
JOSH GROBAN: It was.
I hadn't done proper
theater since senior year
of high school.
So I had some concert
versions of shows.
I had been a part of
some really wonderful
Broadway-themed
musical experiences.
But this was something that
was altogether new for me,
and something that was
an opportunity for me
to get scared again, to
really learn a great deal,
to be a cog in a
really beautiful wheel,
instead of spending 15
years in a solo spotlight.
To be a part of an ensemble,
to be part of a show
where everybody has
each other's back
and is equally responsible for
telling this beautiful story
every night was something that
was really, really appealing
to me.
And I always loved this show.
I was a fan of it since
I saw it in the tent
when it was in the
Meatpacking District.
Loved the character.
Found every character in the
show to be very relatable even
in a contemporary environment.
And just-- I had read
a blurb that they
were thinking of bringing
this to a proscenium,
that they were thinking
of transforming a Broadway
theater.
And I think for those
of us that had loved
the show for a long
time, we all kind of
were equally excited and maybe
a little skeptical about,
is that going to work?
But I was so intrigued.
And I thought, this is a chance
to really take a risk here
and try something that would be
a creative masterclass for me.
And so I did.
I reached out.
And it turned into drinks
with Rachel and Dave.
And it really was just
a creative conversation
about what we believed, how
we believed in the show,
and what we saw in the show,
and whether or not it would fit.
And then I wound up singing
some of the material for Dave
at my apartment.
And it just wound up
being a natural fit.
I in no way, shape,
or form ever wanted
to nudge my way into
something like this.
This was a show that was very
special for me, too, as a fan.
And so it had to
be the right fit.
But thankfully, through
Dave and Rachel's belief
that it could work, and
our hard work, it paid off.
BRENDAN COLLINS: So Josh, you
and Brittain-- separately,
your kind of day
jobs are singers
and performers and
musicians in your own right.
So--
BRITTAIN ASHFORD:
Day job is a stretch.
Because Josh actually gets paid.
[LAUGHTER]
BRENDAN COLLINS: But
the principle-- for
love of the game, right?
BRITTAIN ASHFORD: OK.
BRENDAN COLLINS: You
moonlight as Broadway stars,
is what I'm saying.
So do you find it
interesting or challenging
to go from your onstage
persona during the show back
to your own music?
Has that been interesting?
BRITTAIN ASHFORD: Uh, yes?
Yes and no.
Honestly, I don't have a ton
of time to do my own stuff.
But I found-- I went on
a tour over the summer.
And it's like, this is
actually more my scene.
Like, when I play a show,
this is the kind of room
I'm used to playing.
So it's nice.
Because I can be like,
hey, I like your shirt.
Oh, Michigan.
Yeah!
You know?
I can do that.
Whereas, you can't
do that on Broadway.
That's not cool.
JOSH GROBAN: But the
eye to eye connection
is probably pretty similar.
BRITTAIN ASHFORD: Yes.
It's very similar.
So in that aspect, I think I
was well prepared for that.
But I think it might
be different for you.
JOSH GROBAN: It was.
One of the things Rachel
and I really had to work on
was getting used to
that kind of intimacy
that I had not been used to,
especially on the tour that I
had just come off of,
where you're looking out
at kind of an abyss of people.
And it's very easy, if you're
feeling nervous or feeling
whatever, to just kind of
zone out and look at the mass.
And you've got,
usually, the front row
of people who paid a lot and
are just kind of over it,
and then like--
and you can't really see
the superfans way out
in the back seats.
So it was a little
jarring, I think, at first,
especially singing a show
during my concert tour which
was very much in a style that
I've been doing for 15 years,
and then taking
on a role which we
knew I'd have to kind of rough
up the edges a little bit,
vocally and emotionally,
to get into.
But in the rehearsals,
Rachel really
made sure that we had people
to look at every time,
and to not be afraid to
be kept honest by people
that were right in front
of you at all times.
And that was a different
experience for me.
But it's one that has been
rewarding, and one that--
I will now bother the
people in my front row
when I do my concerts now.
Because it's too much fun.
BRENDAN COLLINS: Yeah.
Related to that,
it's interesting.
Because you can't sit in the
front row of this show and just
be over it.
The show happens around you.
JOSH GROBAN: Oh, you still can.
BRITTAIN ASHFORD:
You definitely can.
JOSH GROBAN: You definitely can.
[LAUGHTER]
Yeah.
There is some stink eye
during the bows where we're
just like, you [MUTTERING]
[LAUGHTER]
BRENDAN COLLINS: But there is--
I mean, granted, that's true.
But--
JOSH GROBAN: Like, why
did you buy that seat?
Sir, why did you buy
that seat if you're
gonna to look at us that way--
BRITTAIN ASHFORD:
My wife bought it.
JOSH GROBAN: My wife bought it.
My wife bought this seat.
BRITTAIN ASHFORD:
I hate theater.
Ugh.
RACHEL CHAVKIN: But
you also never know
who's receiving something.
JOSH GROBAN: That's true.
People--
RACHEL CHAVKIN: Like actually,
it's sort of extraordinary
how individual--
I mean, it's something that
Dave has talked about a lot.
But how much the setting
feels like Tolstoy, in that--
one of the reasons
the book is so long
is because Tolstoy's ambition
is to talk about all of Russia,
from the low to the high,
from the young to the old.
And so we have done that by
casting 1,200 plus people
in our show, which
is the audience.
And so you get this incredible
mixture of humanity.
And one of the best
things in the world
is to watch someone receive
Natasha during her area,
during "No One Else."
And she leans over and
is like, dear diary,
I'm in love for the first time,
and I'm looking at the moon.
And that's absolutely a
one-on-one relationship
with a single person who's
with this 19-year-old,
and in her brain.
And that's an incredibly
romantic thing.
And it's very special
to be that person.
But it's also equally
wonderful to watch
that person receive,
and sort of blossom
if they're open to the contact.
JOSH GROBAN: You can tell
a lot about the person
by how they respond to
especially that scene.
There's the people that look
at Natasha and go, been there,
yeah.
And then there's the people
who are just, like, I've never
felt love in my life.
Be gone, child.
BRITTAIN ASHFORD: One of the
things I really enjoy, and it's
kind of an unexpected
thing, is when
you don't think someone
is having a good time.
Because they are
very close to you.
And they're sitting there.
And they're like--
you think this.
This is my personal
inner monologue.
It's like, they hate this.
Why are they here?
And then they're the
person at the end
of the show who's like--
standing up.
You're like, where
did that come from?
I did not see that coming.
DAVE MALLOY: Actually,
my wife is a performer.
And whenever I go to
her shows I actually
have to sit in the back.
Because apparently I have
a terrible audience face.
RACHEL CHAVKIN: You have
DAVE MALLOY: Because
I'm just like--
[LAUGHTER]
But I'm just soaking it all in.
Like, I'm not making-- it's
just all happening in my head.
And after the show, I'm like,
oh my god, it was so amazing.
You were like-- and
she's like, really?
BRITTAIN ASHFORD: He does this
when you have dinner with him,
too, though.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVE MALLOY: It's just
my thoughtful face.
JOSH GROBAN: Resting thoughtful
face is what we call it.
BRENDAN COLLINS: RTF, yeah.
So speaking of--
I love the idea
that Tolstoy tried
to write a book
about everything.
You know, even the
title "War and Peace."
It's like, that's
half of everything
and the other half
of everything.
BRITTAIN ASHFORD: I think
it's just everything.
BRENDAN COLLINS: Exactly.
But the casting for the show--
I love that it-- you've
talked about this
in past interviews,
where you wanted
to have a similarly kind
of ecumenical approach
to, who is the star of the
show that is about everything?
And the characters
themselves are
kind of ciphers
for whoever happens
to be experiencing that thing.
So can you talk--
I mean, just to quickly call
out some people in the cast.
It's incredibly diverse.
So Natasha's played
by Denee Benton,
who's an African American.
Her understudy last week
while she was on vacation
is South Asian.
RACHEL CHAVKIN: Well, one of--
and I should say, one of two.
Denee has two
understudies, one of whom
is Southeast Asian, who
tragically apparently
is the first Southeast
Asian performer--
BRENDAN COLLINS: Since "Bombay
Dreams" or something like that?
RACHEL CHAVKIN: --in 10 years,
since "Bombay Dreams" to play--
a female-- to play a leading
principal role on Broadway.
And then her other
understudy is a white actress
named Lauren Zakrin,
who's equally wonderful.
But so-- yeah.
Anyway, continue.
BRENDAN COLLINS: Yeah.
No.
And the new Pierre-- this is not
a spoiler-- is Oak Onaodowan,
who was from a little show--
"Hamilton," I think it's called?
[LAUGHTER]
RACHEL CHAVKIN: I haven't--
JOSH GROBAN: [INAUDIBLE]
for a minute.
RACHEL CHAVKIN: Can
you get me tickets?
BRENDAN COLLINS: But he's
also African American.
And so you have this show
about 19th century Russia.
And if you were--
your knee-jerk reaction would
be to not necessarily cast
the people you've cast.
So can you walk me
through the decision
behind to make it what it is?
RACHEL CHAVKIN: Sure.
You want-- I'll--
DAVE MALLOY: Ooh!
Well, I mean, yeah.
One thing to start with--
I think going back to
that idea that Tolstoy
was trying to talk
about everything
that was 19th century
Russia at that moment.
And so we are taking
that story, but now we're
telling that story in 21st
century New York City,
and 21st century America.
And so I think one
of the amazing things
about the staging,
and what we've
been talking about and the
intimacy of the staging,
is everyone is both the
character and themselves.
We are very much this
troupe of actors in New York
City doing this story.
So yeah.
So we just wanted the
casting to reflect, well,
what does 21st century
America look like?
In the same way that Tolstoy
was like, what does 19th century
Russia look like?
And 21st century America
is beautifully diverse.
So we wanted a
beautifully diverse cast.
BRENDAN COLLINS: So yeah.
That's lovely.
Thank you.
Just to quickly go back to the
audience participation element
to the show.
Aside from the now
legendary phone
throwing incident of
2013-- and those of you
who know what I'm talking
about, look it up.
The show-- it's incredible how--
you mentioned you
allow the audience
to be incredibly connected
to the people on stage.
Have there been any special
moments, either one on one
or where people maybe
after the show come up
and say, oh, this meant a lot
to me because of X, Y, or Z,
or because someone on
stage did have a reaction
you weren't expecting?
RACHEL CHAVKIN: I think
there are so many.
JOSH GROBAN: Lucas Steele,
who is so, so wonderful,
plays Anatole.
Whenever we're off stage
during intermission,
I always kind of debrief him
on the reaction of people.
He has this flirty moment in
the top of the show where he'll
reach over and he'll maybe
scoot the date or the husband
to the side and
flirt with the wife.
And he whispers in their ear.
And then they always kind of
say something back to him.
And then he goes
on with the scene.
And there was one night
where it wasn't a whisper.
He did the whisper into her ear.
And she just-- we all could
hear her go, wow of wows!
[LAUGHTER]
And I think most of
them happen with Lucas.
He also does this thing where he
scoots somebody over and tells
them about this Russian
custom where everybody
has to sit down and be quiet.
And he's got his mic right here.
And the lady was
next to the mic.
And she just goes, oh!
Oh
[LAUGHTER]
I don't know.
I just-- I like the Lucas
interactions because they're
usually the loudest.
BRENDAN COLLINS: Yeah.
And the character-- Lucas is a
very handsome man, I must say.
JOSH GROBAN: Adonis.
BRENDAN COLLINS: But
the character he plays
is almost this ethereal
David Bowie come to earth.
RACHEL CHAVKIN:
That was absolutely
the image for casting it.
BRENDAN COLLINS: And so he
has a very striking presence
whenever he's on stage.
But so does kind of
everybody else in the show.
JOSH GROBAN: Somebody on
Twitter called him a sex alien.
BRENDAN COLLINS: A sex alien.
Yeah.
BRITTAIN ASHFORD: That's fair.
JOSH GROBAN: That's
pretty much--
BRENDAN COLLINS: So Rachel,
I'm glad you mentioned this.
And I meant to mention this
at the top of the show--
that all four of you,
in addition to I think
19 other cast members and the
majority of the creative staff
are making their
debuts on Broadway.
To have 19 people make
their debut in the same show
is virtually unheard of.
I mean, when they bring
productions over from the West
End, sometimes that happens.
But it's pretty unprecedented.
So were you and Dave and
any of the other-- sort
of the brass behind the show--
were you nervous at all?
Or were you pretty confident?
RACHEL CHAVKIN: Yeah.
No, I mean, of course
we were nervous.
Um--
DAVE MALLOY: There was
one running refrain
during rehearsals, and
during tech especially, where
Rachel and the
choreographer Sam Pinkleton
would be doing some thing
and trying to problem-solve
some bit of staging.
And then one of them
would turn to the other
and go, well, what do
they do in real Broadway?
RACHEL CHAVKIN: Yeah.
Yeah.
Actually, our dance captain--
former dance captain-- Paloma
Garcia-Lee became the go-to.
Because she's done a
lot of Broadway shows.
And so we would say, what
would they do on real Broadway?
And then very nicely she titled
this extraordinary Broadway.
And I mean, yes, of course we
were deeply nervous about it.
And then also on the flip
side, I can't imagine--
I mean, again, because we've
gotten to grow this so slowly--
you know, we started development
of this show in 2011.
There's no work of art I've ever
directed or probably will ever
direct that I know as
well as I know this show.
And I love this show.
And I know it's good.
And we knew it
worked, and that it
had all the different
elements of high
and low and epic and
intimate, and was funny,
and is devastating emotionally.
So in a sense, actually, I was
very delighted to find out,
like, tech is tech is tech.
And I've been training for that
since I began doing theater
when I was in college.
So it felt sort of
at home, actually,
and has been really amazing.
I went bowling last night
with the Broadway league
for the first time.
And it's really wonderful
to walk into this community
and be like, ah, there's this
wonderful community here of all
these people who are making
a living, who are helping
to run our city, who are
making our city the place
that I want to live in.
And everyone's a bad bowler.
[LAUGHTER]
BRENDAN COLLINS: So we
have two audience mics.
So if you want to line up and
ask questions of the cast,
we can do that in just a bit.
But I have one more question for
the group before we open it up.
So now it's pretty
common-- and Josh,
you mentioned that
you actually did
this when you saw the show
when it was in the Meatpacking
District.
You get a chance to meet a lot
of really established people,
either in the Broadway community
or superfans who also happen
to be crazy mega celebrities.
So was there anyone
that you've met
because of the show that
made you say, like, whoa,
this is real now?
This is sort of my
moment of arrival.
DAVE MALLOY: Well,
Neil deGrasse Tyson--
JOSH GROBAN: I was going
to mention Dr. Tyson.
DAVE MALLOY: Yeah.
That was--
JOSH GROBAN: We have a
show about a great comet.
And Dr. Neil deGrasse Tyson
comes by you're like--
BRENDAN COLLINS: As long as he
didn't go to Twitter afterward
and say, like, actually, what
the comet would have done--
[LAUGHTER]
JOSH GROBAN: You know,
we've had a bunch
of people that have come by that
we've really been inspired by.
I mean, it's a
little bit jarring,
especially when
they sit on stage
and, you know,
they're at a table.
And you know, Dr. Tyson
was just to my left.
And I'm singing the first song.
And I'm just kind of--
all right, well.
That's a whole set
of nerves I'm just
going to have a handle for
the next 2 and 1/2 hours.
Yeah.
BRENDAN COLLINS: Lucas didn't
try to seduce him or anything?
JOSH GROBAN: No, he was
in the wrong seat for that
unfortunately.
BRENDAN COLLINS: OK.
So we can take an
audience question.
AUDIENCE: Hi everyone.
Thanks for coming.
I've seen the show twice and
was blown away both times.
I completely fell
in love with it.
And Josh, I've been a fan
of yours for a long time.
JOSH GROBAN: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So yeah.
I really love the show.
Touching on the
audience participation,
has there ever been a time when
things have gone really wrong?
Like, there's a lot
of things to trip on.
There are some times when maybe
the audience doesn't-- when you
try to participate with them,
that they may not react the way
you thought that
they would, or--
RACHEL CHAVKIN: Yeah.
I mean, the two--
the cell phone incident was
certainly a remarkable one
in many of our lives,
where a cell phone
was chucked across the space.
That had nothing to do
with the show actually,
but was the audience
on themselves.
I think probably the moment in
the show that's most open to--
it's like there's
a little bit of,
how's this gonna
go every night-- is
the passing of the letter to
Natasha at the top of Act Two.
AUDIENCE: That took like
five minutes in my show
before the guy realized
what he was supposed to do.
RACHEL CHAVKIN: Right.
So-- right.
So A, if it takes
a very long time
it can step on Lucas's moment,
who's singing his guts out.
The audience member does
have to traverse some stairs.
So there have been
things that happen there.
And then there have been
equally wonderful things.
Like one of my favorite moments,
that people still talk about
who were in the tent
production, is we had a woman,
quote unquote, "mom-dance
it" over to Natasha.
And it was just wonderful.
It was like whole dance
solo that happened
in the middle of the tent.
So anyway, that's a moment
that's certainly open to, um,
fail blogs.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
BRENDAN COLLINS: But it's nice.
It's almost like walking
on stage with a grenade.
And you're about to pull the
pin, and you're just like,
I hope I can get this away
from my body in enough time.
BRITTAIN ASHFORD: Pretty much.
JOSH GROBAN: Every
night, you don't know.
You don't know what
you're going to get,
which keeps it
exciting for sure.
BRENDAN COLLINS: We'll
take a question over here.
AUDIENCE: Everyone,
thank you for coming.
I have a question for
Brittain, actually.
In your singing style, you bring
a very unique, almost folkish
style to the voice of Sonya.
I was curious how you
conceived of that,
and how that connects
to the character.
BRITTAIN ASHFORD:
Well, I was born.
[LAUGHTER]
And I don't know.
I just-- I have been
singing since I was a kid.
I never really had
any proper training.
And I definitely listened to--
not even a lot of folk music.
I listened to, pretty much, I
think, oldies when I was a kid.
And I loved musical theater
when I was in high school.
And I definitely
never got any parts
when I was in high
school, I think
because I just didn't
understand how musicals worked,
and how I needed to be singing.
Which is something I
really appreciate about--
something I actually really
love about being in this show
is that I am not a
"Broadway singer."
But it's just kind
of-- it's nothing
I've intentionally done.
I've definitely been asked
if it's an affectation.
Actually, a celebrity I
admire very, very, very much
came backstage and was
very complimentary,
but then asked me,
is that your voice?
Or is that an affectation?
And I was like, uh, no, sir.
That's my voice.
It's so nice to meet you.
JOSH GROBAN: Dr. Tyson.
Yeah,
BRITTAIN ASHFORD: Dr. Tyson.
No.
It was not.
It was not the good doctor.
But yeah, I feel fortunate
that I can just sort of be me.
And I know Dave, when he wrote
"Sonya Alone," he wrote it
for me--
DAVE MALLOY: For you.
BRITTAIN ASHFORD: --based
on my music and my band.
So in that sense, I
feel really lucky when
I just get to go in there
and I get to just do--
like, that's what I do.
And I feel really lucky
to be able to do that.
DAVE MALLOY: Well, and that's
a big thing actually for a lot
of the casting of this show.
We don't cast people and
then tell them how to sing.
We cast people who
sing in amazing ways.
So I had known Brittain's solo
work as a singer-songwriter,
and just loved her voice.
And so I very much wrote
the role for her voice.
Yeah.
And that's true--
I mean, that's true of
Josh's song as well.
Josh has a big song in Act
One that was written newly
for the Broadway version.
"Dust and Ashes" was
written for Josh's voice.
Because I'm like, ooh.
Josh has a pretty good voice.
[LAUGHTER]
Maybe I could write
a song for that.
JOSH GROBAN: I am grateful.
BRITTAIN ASHFORD: All I can--
BRENDAN COLLINS: You
should go pro with that.
JOSH GROBAN: But yeah.
To that point, I mean, for
me, just as a fan and muso
first, to be surrounded
by such uniqueness--
and there is not a single
cookie cutter in any way, shape,
or form with anybody in the
creative cast, backstage
and on stage, with the show.
There is so much nuance.
There was so much deep
brilliance and uniqueness
to every single person that's
up there that, you know,
it felt very much like home.
We all are coming
from different worlds.
If you all the bios
in the playbill,
there are 10 projects that
every one of these Broadway cast
members have done before
they went to Broadway.
This is not, for many
of us, not something
that is normal for us.
So I think that's one
of the things that
makes the show so special.
RACHEL CHAVKIN: Yeah.
And if I can just
add on to that,
but that goes back to the
question about diversity.
I mean, it's tragic
to me that we're still
having a conversation about
why it's revolutionary
that Oak or Denee should be
playing either of the titular
roles in a play set in
19th century Russia.
But more so, actually,
or equally, in the cast
is this incredible diversity,
as Josh is talking about,
of talent and background.
It's why there are
so many debuts.
Because very few of us came up
through any sort of pipeline
to this moment.
And the unpredictability
of that is
part of the chaos that is
in the culture of this show.
And I think it's what makes it
such a nice place to live in.
BRITTAIN ASHFORD: I also
think that if I had attempted
to pursue a musical life, a
musical theater life starting
from college, I would not
be the person I am now.
I would not be in this show.
I think I would
have been probably
thoroughly disappointed and
shut out a long time ago.
I mean, or I just
kept making rock music
in basements and stuff.
I'd be fine.
BRENDAN COLLINS: Cool.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you so much
for being here.
Dave, this is a
question for you.
Having played Pierre, but
also being the composer,
do you feel like you're
more self-critical of either
of those aspects of yourself?
Or is it just normal separation?
DAVE MALLOY: Oh, I'm
critical of every aspect.
I mean, actually it
was an amazing thing.
And you know, Rachel can
speak to the frustration
of having your lead--
one of your lead actors
also being the composer.
Because I basically just--
I didn't act until about
a week before we opened.
Because like, I'll
be trying to act.
And I'd be like, what
is the oboe doing?
And it's just very
hard for me to switch
those parts of my brain.
So for me, actually, it was
such a gift and a blessing
to finally step out of the show.
And when we first did the show
at Ars Nova we were just 10
of us.
There were no understudies.
It was just us.
So we just had to do the show.
So I never had the
opportunity to step out.
And when we finally
transferred off-Broadway,
we initially had understudies.
And then people
took over the role.
And then I was finally
actually able to step outside
of the acting and
just watch the writing
and just watch the composing.
And then I was like, oh, yeah.
There's some problems.
Which is actually
one of the reasons
it was so great to be able
to come back to the work
when we transferred
to ART in Boston,
and to really expand
the role of Pierre.
Because I think that actually
was kind of my blind spot.
Because I was playing
Pierre at first,
I didn't recognize
that, oh, he really
could have more meaty of a
story, especially in Act One.
And so that was
what led to writing
the song "Dust and Ashes."
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JOSH GROBAN: And I
should also mention
that Dave will be returning
to the role of Pierre--
DAVE MALLOY: [NERVOUS NOISE]
JOSH GROBAN: --for
a few select dates
in May that I am
very excited for.
DAVE MALLOY: We decided
for those performances,
instead of "Dust and
Ashes," I'll just
be performing "My Ding-A-Ling."
JOSH GROBAN: Oh, I
love "My Ding-A-Ling."
DAVE MALLOY: It's just
a much easier song.
JOSH GROBAN: Oh, hell of a song.
Hell of a song.
DAVE MALLOY: So yeah.
It's good.
JOSH GROBAN: Yeah.
The same rooted existential
agony in both songs.
Which is actually an
interesting point, Dave.
Because now, I mean,
especially with--
not necessarily that we're
in an era after "Hamilton."
But this idea that you can sort
of be a jack-of-all-trades,
and you can be the
person who wrote it--
it was your baby
from start to finish.
And now you're in the show.
Does that intimidate you
now that you're on Broadway?
To say, like, I
have to perform now.
This is my thing.
DAVE MALLOY: No.
I mean, I'm so excited.
Yeah.
I mean, I haven't
done it yet, either.
So who knows?
Maybe I'll just collapse,
just deer in the headlights.
No.
I'm so excited to go
back on and do it.
And yeah, the show
does feel like my baby.
So to come back-- and
the role, especially.
Again, Pierre is just my
favorite character in fiction.
And he's the character
I relate to the most.
So to be able to step
back into that role
and embody it, in this
beautiful theater,
with this beautiful cast--
I'm so excited to do it.
BRENDAN COLLINS:
And having seen now
a couple Pierres having
taken the mantle,
do you find that you're taking
bits of each performance
and planning on incorporating
it into your own?
DAVE MALLOY: Tot--
I mean, I think that's happening
on a subconscious level,
for sure.
It was so funny.
When I first stepped out,
and would watch my understudy
for the first time, I'd go
to Rachel after a performance
and go, you know, I usually
put my hand in my pocket there.
And I noticed that
Luke didn't do that.
Could you maybe
speak to him about--
it's pretty important that he
puts his hand in his pocket
right at that moment.
And then Rachel
was like, OK, Dave.
[LAUGHTER]
But now I've learned
that different actors can
have different interpretations!
JOSH GROBAN: My pants
don't even have pockets.
So--
DAVE MALLOY: Oh.
JOSH GROBAN: Yeah.
The Broadway pants, you'll
be horrified to know,
don't have pockets.
DAVE MALLOY: I'll have
to put that in my rider.
I demand pockets.
BRENDAN COLLINS: Cool.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Not so
much a question,
but a thank you for Rachel.
Having grown up in Russia,
what you just said--
I could never think
that I would heard
two words in the same sentence.
You said Natasha's bat mitzvah.
[LAUGHTER]
Thank you for that.
BRENDAN COLLINS: So now
that the show is kind of--
the same kind of thing,
of the modern musical.
Because of how the
internet works,
it kind of can snowball and
take on a life of its own
to build a fan base and build
this rabid core of people
who are obsessed with the show.
You know, you've seen now
that there's Tumblrs--
several of them--
dedicated to the show.
The fans are
manifesting themselves
in a lot of different new ways.
So especially for you,
Josh, coming from--
not a different line
of work, but this
is your first time on
Broadway, and Brittain too.
Do you find that the fan
experience is any different now
than it maybe would have
been 10, 15 years ago?
JOSH GROBAN: I mean, it's been
really gratifying to see--
and Brittain touched
on it a little bit
earlier-- just
for me personally,
my fan base kind of going a
little bit out of their comfort
zone, of what they're
used to, and embracing
this new adventure, and
embracing this work.
And I'll see sometimes
some fans that I'm
used to seeing in my concert
world coming to 10 shows,
and wanting to see
it from every angle.
That means so much to me.
And on the flip
side of that, people
who maybe don't know anything
about me, from the Broadway
community, that have also been
so supportive and so welcoming.
Whenever you can do something
artistically that can really
blend and educate
and give people
what they didn't know they
wanted, it's such a win-win.
And so some things are the same.
I still get, you know, dolls.
That's pretty
consistent, really.
I don't know why I
get a lot of dolls.
But I get dolls of myself.
I don't get--
BRITTAIN ASHFORD: Some
very skillfully made dolls.
JOSH GROBAN: I'm the last
person who needs or wants
a doll of myself.
And yet, there they
are at Stage Door.
So--
DAVE MALLOY: My opening
night gift was a doll.
JOSH GROBAN: He did.
He got me a doll.
DAVE MALLOY: But I didn't
know that was a thing.
JOSH GROBAN: Well,
it was a nice--
DAVE MALLOY: I
thought, like, I'm
going to really wow everyone.
This is like the most creative,
unique opening night gift
anyone has ever done.
JOSH GROBAN: But it wasn't
a doll of me, though.
It was like-- it was a
traditional nesting doll,
wasn't it?
DAVE MALLOY: No, no.
I gave you a doll of you.
JOSH GROBAN: Of me?
[LAUGHTER]
BRITTAIN ASHFORD: Josh
already threw it out.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
JOSH GROBAN: Well I love it.
[LAUGHTER]
DAVE MALLOY: I didn't make it.
I--
BRITTAIN ASHFORD: Yeah.
He paid someone else to make it.
I don't know if that's--
DAVE MALLOY: Is that worse?
BRITTAIN ASHFORD: I don't know.
DAVE MALLOY: Let's
change the topic.
JOSH GROBAN: Whoever makes
the best doll, let's just--
BRITTAIN ASHFORD:
Back to the question.
I think it's been really
exciting to connect
to a different type of fan base.
The internet has allowed
for that to happen.
I mean, certainly
there's people that
are really excited about
the show who have never
seen the show, who may never
see the show, particularly
young people.
For me, traveling
around, I found
that my demographic was one
very narrow strip of people.
And it generally leaned
more towards young men
aged 21 through 35, and
then young women 21 to 35.
But now I find that I
have this growing fan base
of, like, rabid teenage girls.
And for me, I love that.
Just because it's so--
it feels very rewarding.
And it feels very sweet
and genuine to get a letter
from a 16-year-old girl who's
like, I love your voice.
I love your character.
I love your song that
you sing to Natasha.
I love what that
means for friendship,
for women everywhere.
And like-- and
like, for me, that's
way more rewarding than, like,
hey, uh, what are you drinking?
You know?
So that is--
I don't know.
That's very rewarding for
me to experience that.
JOSH GROBAN: Was that the 21 to
35-year-old man you just did?
BRITTAIN ASHFORD: Yeah.
JOSH GROBAN: OK.
BRITTAIN ASHFORD: That's
me after the show,
in whatever town I'm in,
that I'm like, oh god.
Hey, I liked your set.
BRENDAN COLLINS:
The 25-year-old man
sounds a lot like the
old "over it" guy also.
BRITTAIN ASHFORD: It's
actually the same guy.
BRENDAN COLLINS: It's
Harvey Fierstein, basically.
JOSH GROBAN: Or the
Simpsons comic book guy.
BRITTAIN ASHFORD: Yeah.
JOSH GROBAN: What is
it you are drinking?
Yeah.
The letters are pretty
inspiring-- what
the show means to people.
And especially,
like you said, when
somebody young who's a
student, or somebody who's
thinking about going into
this, when they write
to you that this has
opened their eyes of what's
possible in theater,
it immediately
brings you back full
circle to those moments
when you were inspired,
and you were that age,
and you were feeling insecure,
and lacking vision or a path.
And it was art
and it was theater
that gave you direction.
And it was arts education
that gave you a voice.
When you get those letters from
people that tell you that this
show has been that guide,
at least in some small way,
for them, that's--
I think I'm with
Brittain on that.
That's my favorite, favorite
part of doing this show.
BRENDAN COLLINS: Cool.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So coming in as
somebody who knew
the show was based
on "War and Peace"
and not a whole lot else, it
was really surprising to me
that Andrey isn't here.
And that's sort of the point.
And it works really
well as a reflection
of Natasha and Pierre.
But I'm wondering
if there was ever
any temptation to
cut away to him
and show his part of the war?
RACHEL CHAVKIN:
We're talking and--
DAVE MALLOY: Part two.
RACHEL CHAVKIN: Yeah.
Dave and I really want to make
a 150-person site-specific
outside version of the
Battle of Austerlitz
that would be just that battle.
So there is actually this--
JOSH GROBAN: Like a Rosencrantz
and Guildenstern version.
RACHEL CHAVKIN: Anyone
wanna make that happen?
Yeah.
So I think it was strongly
clear right from that very first
lyric, "and Andrey isn't
here," that his presence needed
to be very restrained and
repressed in this piece.
But I think also our love
for that character is huge,
and you know, somebody
may lead to future work.
BRENDAN COLLINS: Cool.
And we'll take
one more question.
AUDIENCE: I have
another question.
So on the topic of your singing
tonight, how do you maintain--
in a show that's actually
really an opera more than even
a musical--
your vocal stamina
and physical stamina?
Because it's also a
very physical show?
There's a lot of dancing
and running around.
JOSH GROBAN: Sleep.
I mean, truthfully, it's--
BRITTAIN ASHFORD: Wait.
You sleep?
JOSH GROBAN: Very rarely.
But when I do, I feel
much better onstage.
I think that you
start to learn--
well, this show's
been good for me
because it actually pushed where
I thought my boundaries had
previously been.
I'm used to singing
17, 18 songs a night.
But I'm also used
to taking a day off
after every couple of shows.
The thought of doing
eight shows a week
was frankly terrifying for me,
especially with a show that
required so much kind
of yell-singing, for me,
and gravelness to
his voice, and stuff
that I was just-- as
somebody who's always thought
of vocal health
consciousness first,
it was just kind
of a worry of mine,
going into it knowing I'd
have to do 300 of these.
So it's actually
taught me a lot that I
didn't know I was able to
do, which has been really
rewarding and educational.
But at the same time, you start
to learn about the monk mode
that you need to kind
of go into to recharge.
And it's actually pretty
fast if you let it be--
if you don't burn the
candle and you actually get
sleep and you try to do
good stuff for your brain.
You know, I can't
be a total monk,
because then I wind
up resenting it.
So you have to be
social and do stuff.
But at the same time you've got
to really listen to your body.
And I that this, doing
Broadway, teaches
you to be really keen to that.
BRITTAIN ASHFORD:
For me, it's been
about recognizing my
boundaries before I
hit them, which is
something I was never
very good about before, or
never really had to think about.
Because when you're doing
your own stuff, also,
it's that you can have a
moment where you're like,
oh, I can't sing this one song.
Because I just maybe yelled
too much a little last night.
You don't have to.
It's your decision to not.
But in a show where you
have to do the show--
there's no way around that--
you know that you can't
scream the night before.
So for me, it's just
been-- in addition
to what Josh said,
getting rest and making
sure you're taking
care of your health--
it's knowing your boundaries
before you hit them.
And for me, that's
been really useful.
And I'm like, you know what?
I really want to
go out. tonight.
But I can't.
Or like, man, another
whiskey sounds great.
But smart person brain
says, maybe not tonight.
You know?
So I think that's been critical.
JOSH GROBAN: And the
other great thing
about having a cast to lean on
is that you get a chance to,
as you're singing through
the show, kind of clock
where you're at each night.
And so every night
feels different.
I come out and I sing
the first few lines
of my very, very first song.
And I just go, hm.
OK.
Well, that's where I'm at today.
And I know exactly where
I need to put my voice
or put my energy level in
order to get to song seven,
and do that successfully.
So you start to learn a little
bit about energy management,
vocal management-- in no
way, shape, or form that
affects what you're giving
to the audience each
and every night.
That's always consistent.
But internally, you
learn a lot about--
like you said, you
can't change anything.
The domino effect starts the
moment those double doors open.
So you learn about that, which
has been very helpful too.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
BRENDAN COLLINS: So
one last question--
I feel like a wonderful
spine that's been involved--
I mean, that's kind
of woven its way
through this whole
conversation--
is that everyone here is kind of
doing this for the first time.
And when there is
maybe a second time,
what is the number
one lesson that you've
learned from doing this?
DAVE MALLOY: Are we
supposed to learn things?
[LAUGHTER]
JOSH GROBAN: I was told
there wouldn't be a quiz.
I think that the bar for
me has been so raised.
And I've been so lucky as a
first going out that there
has been such a specialness.
Everything that we've mentioned
in the last hour about what
makes this cast unique,
this story unique, this
show unique--
that's a huge
creative bar for me
that I'm so
fortunate and humbled
to have started
with on Broadway,
which is a very unusual
thing to have started with.
We all, I think, feel
lucky in that same way.
So I think for me,
whatever next adventure,
I would make sure that I hold
to the same standard of doing
something that maybe
is less expected,
that is an educational
experience, maybe not so
down the middle.
And surround myself
with creative people
that I know I'm going to learn
a great, great deal from.
And I think that if
the next going out
doesn't continue to
meet those criteria,
then I would feel like the
bar was lowered a little bit.
But it has to be challenging
to me in those ways, I think,
going forward.
RACHEL CHAVKIN: Yeah.
It's funny.
I think, actually-- there
have been many, many lessons
in terms of just, like,
literally just this is
what a tech process looks like.
And this is when they need your
set designs, and all of that.
But I think spiritually maybe
one of the biggest things
really does come from
Howard Kagan, who's
our producer, who I think-- and
I say this as a female leader.
I think my default as--
and I don't know that this is
tied to my femaleness or not,
but it's to take care and
to know what is being feared
and try to ameliorate that--
did I use that word right?
Address that fear
before we get there,
and make things achievable.
And potentially debase or
lower an idea a little bit.
And right from the
start, Howard was
very encouraging of being
uncompromising in what
we had achieved at Ars Nova--
scenically, spiritually,
the levels of that show--
and saying we could do that
a first in the tent and then
on Broadway.
And that we didn't
have to sacrifice.
And there were, of course,
painful choices and ideas
that were killed
in that process.
But actually the encouragement--
beginning to think about
how this show tours.
And him relentlessly saying,
don't start with reality,
actually.
Start with what would the
ideal be of what the show looks
like on the road, when you
have a day or a couple days
to go into a space, versus
the four-week load-in process
that we had for transforming
a Broadway house.
And that's been very
bolstering, and is
something I'll take forward.
BRENDAN COLLINS: Great.
Well, thank you all very much.
Just a quick-- some plugs.
You can get tickets to "Natasha,
Pierre, and the Great Comet
of 1812" on telecharge.com.
Josh, when are you
wrapping up your stint?
JOSH GROBAN: I'm a little
over the halfway point.
So I'm going to
be done July 2nd.
BRENDAN COLLINS: July 2nd.
And Dave, do you know-- you'll
be doing a couple of specific
dates that are listed on the--
DAVE MALLOY: I believe my
first date is May 4th--
RACHEL CHAVKIN: 4th.
DAVE MALLOY: 4th.
Oh yeah.
Because it's Star Wars Day.
BRENDAN COLLINS: It is, yeah.
DAVE MALLOY: Which is like--
oh, I'm so excited about that.
RACHEL CHAVKIN: You can't
call out your first day,
you know that?
DAVE MALLOY: What's that?
RACHEL CHAVKIN: You can't
call out your first day.
To go see Star Wars.
DAVE MALLOY: But I can call out
to Star Wars on the first day.
BRENDAN COLLINS: Yeah.
It is your show.
So no one is going
to correct you,
really-- well, Rachel, you
probably would correct him.
RACHEL CHAVKIN: Yeah.
BRENDAN COLLINS: Great.
So thank you all.
Can I get a round of
applause for our guests?
[APPLAUSE]